sometimes occasionally I play video
games and I do this despite the fact
that I'm really not very good at them
some would say terrible yeah yeah I'm in
back yeah anyway this year I ventured
into mobile games thanks to our good
friends at Google Play and earlier today
literally just a couple hours ago on
stream cocoa I played the very popular
game clash Royale with the number one
ranked eSports team complexity yes these
kids are amazing check out this clip
don't take yeah exactly that works did I
win
do you know was it close at all was
there anything that I did accidentally
like let's say you let a dog loose a
wild dog in a chemistry class and he
accidentally bumps into a couple of
beakers and for a second it's like wait
a minute I think that dog accidentally
did something absolutely yeah actually
you had a Sparky and the princess killed
the skeletons and then killed the wizard
and the witch that was good yeah do you
ever listen to yourself seriously if you
walk into any emergency room in this
country and said I had a Sparkie and a
witch and then a skeleton they would
medicate you immediately
we're nice fellow take devote their life
to that game you're to see the full
stream and all the other Google Play
games that I've tried out go to
youtube.com slash Team Coco
you